Choosing someone to take over a role
from another actor is never easy,
especially when the original actor drew praise
for their take on a character. In the case of
these casting switcheroos, the change was
just too drastic for audiences to endure.
When Ridley Scott signed on to direct
the Silence of the Lambs sequel,
he did so without his Clarice Starling in place.
Anthony Hopkins had already negotiated a return to
the role of Hannibal Lecter, but Jodie Foster
didn't share his enthusiasm for the second
chapter in the serial killer's story, despite
winning an Oscar for the role in the first film.
She later told Total Film, "The official reason I
didn't do Hannibal is I was doing another movie,
Flora Plum. So I get to say, in a nice,
dignified way, that I wasn't available when
that movie was being shot. But Clarice meant
so much to [Lambs director Jonathan Demme]
and I … there was no way that either
of us could really trample on her."
"Now that's really interesting,
Clarice. I'm really pressed for time."
Several big name actresses were considered to
take her place, and the part ultimately went
to Julianne Moore. While both Scott and Hopkins
were happy with the choice, audiences weren't as
convinced. Moore was inevitably compared to Foster
and couldn't measure up to her predecessor's
screen savvy nor rekindle the creepy connection
Clarice had shared with Hopkins in the first film.
Jodie Foster offered her own diplomatic
but shady take on the film, saying, simply,
"I saw Hannibal. I won't comment."
The Mummy was a surprise smash for Universal,
posting global receipts of $415 million and
landing on the top 10 highest-grossing films
of 1999. It launched Brendan Fraser's career
as a Hollywood action hero and introduced the
world to a stunning new leading lady in Rachel
Weisz. The pair made a compelling onscreen couple
and reprised their roles in The Mummy Returns,
which managed to bring in a nice
haul from the box office as well.
But by the time the third film came
around, Weisz was suffering from some
serious Mummy fatigue and stepped aside.
Weisz was rumored to call the script for
the Mummy 3 "crap," so the studio turned
to Maria Bello to fill in for the role.
"That should give us a good advantage."
Unfortunately for Bello, her turn in the role
was criticized for lacking the charm of the
original and the film failed to recoup its
production costs in the domestic box office.
"Hahhahaa, why am I laughing?"
The '90s marked a moment of resurgence for
Disney's animated film collection, with films like
Beauty and the Beast and The Lion King offering a
new generation of children some cartoon movies to
sing along to. One of Disney's most beloved films
of the era was Aladdin, an Oscar-winning take on
the Arabic folk tale about the street thief who
shed his rags and won the heart of a princess.
Aladdin was packed full of great musical
numbers, but the main reason it became
such a smash was the input of the
late Robin Williams as the Genie.
"It's all part and parcel,
the whole Genie gig. Phenomenal cosmic
power … itty bitty living space."
The actor confirmed that he wouldn't be
lending his voice to the direct-to-video
sequel The Return of Jafar after an alleged
row with Disney over its marketing tactics,
so the search for a new Genie began.
Dan Castellaneta, the legendary voice of Homer
Simpson, was ultimately chosen to voice the big
blue guy, but the Simpsons star just couldn't
measure up to Williams' frenetic performance.
The quality of the animation didn't help matters,
but Castellaneta lacked the unpredictability that
Williams brought to the Genie, essentially doing
a watered-down impression of his predecessor.
"D'oh!"
There are five films based on Tom Clancy's Jack
Ryan books, but only one actor has played the
protagonist twice. Eyebrows were raised when Alec
Baldwin was given the boot after he successfully
debuted Ryan on-screen in The Hunt for the
Red October. Baldwin later implied that the
studio had gone behind his back and entered into
negotiations with Ford to take the role of Ryan.
"Well that was a guess, but it seemed logical."
Even so, Ford's performance in Patriot Games and
Clear and Present Danger became
definitive for the character.
Eight years later, another actor stepped
in to bring a much younger version of Jack
Ryan to the big screen. This time, it
was Ben Affleck who stepped in for The
Sum of All Fears. His performance
in the role was met with disdain,
however, and the Jack Ryan franchise
never really recovered after that,
despite an attempt to reboot it with Chris
Pine in the lead more than a decade later.
Following in the footsteps of Linda Hamilton
as Sarah Connor in the Terminator franchise
was never going to be easy for any actress.
Hamilton gave a performance so layered and
compelling that even the most talented
performers would have struggled to do the
character justice. The first to give it a shot
was Lena Headey, who was cast in the role in
the short-lived TV series Terminator: The Sarah
Connor Chronicles. Fox cancelled the show after
two seasons citing its high cost as a reason,
but Headey's Game of Thrones colleague Emilia
Clarke was willing to give it another go on
the silver screen for Terminator: Genisys.
The film was a box office dud and was heavily
criticized for using the old time travel chestnut
to rewrite the beginning of the Terminator
story to suit the filmmakers' purposes. The
main problem wasn't the infuriatingly muddled
timeline, though. It was the casting. As much
as TV lovers might dig Clarke's portrayal
of Daenerys Targaryen in Game of Thrones,
the film crowd was decidedly not
wowed by her run as Sarah Connor,
where her line deliveries packed a
lot less punch than the original.
"Come with me if you want to live."
Pass.
National Lampoon's Van Wilder isn't going to be
preserved in the Library of Congress National
Film Registry anytime soon. Yet for all its
failings, fans of a certain age remember this
movie fondly. This was a time when frat humor
was at its peak, and sitting down to watch a
comedy usually meant turning your brain off for
90 minutes. Van Wilder might not have been the
most cerebral comedy of all time, but Ryan
Reynolds still delivered as the fast-talking
cool guy who threw the best parties and was
a softie underneath all those crazy antics.
After the Kal Penn-led sequel
was destroyed by critics,
the producers decided their next move
would be a prequel featuring a younger
version of Van Wilder. Reynolds refused
to return to the role, so they brought in
Mean Girls' Jonathan Bennett for Van Wilder:
Freshman Year — which was a terrible mistake.
"I have never seen such a
sorry display in all my life."
The actor couldn't come close to
the charisma of his predecessor and
produced a feature-length failed
impression effort as a result.
Major League was a surprise grand slam
for Paramount Pictures and produced two
increasingly terrible sequels. And while
Charlie Sheen's Wild Thing came back for
a second round at the mound in Major
League II, there was another standout
actor from the first film who refused to
run the bases of this franchise again.
Wesley Snipes, whose charming swagger as the
speedy base thief was a homerun in the first
movie, had no interest in returning to the
dugout for the second movie. At the time,
he was well on his way to becoming
a Hollywood MVP in his own right,
thanks to movies like White Men Can't Jump
and Demolition Man, so he pretty much priced
himself out of the second movie. With the
Cleveland Indians down a man on the roster,
the filmmakers turned to relative newcomer Omar
Epps to sub in as pinch runner for the project.
Unfortunately, Epps didn't
have a strong background in
comedy and his performance was the
cinematic equivalent of a foul ball.
"Read some of your reviews man. One guy
said Willie Mays Hayes couldn't play dead."
Just a bit outside.
The Prisoner of Azkaban might still be
a favorite among some Harry Potter fans,
thanks to the arrival of Sirius Black and
that wild whomping willow. But the fact
remains that it's the lowest grossing movie
in the franchise, and for many, the subdued
enthusiasm seems to stem from the unfortunate
arrival of a new Hogwarts headmaster in the film.
Richard Harris' take on Albus Dumbledore in
the first two movies had become definitive
for Potter fans. So when the actor died
after a battle with Hodgkin's disease,
the filmmakers had to turn to another actor
to step into the beloved professor's cloak.
Michael Gambon seemed like a fine choice
to conjure up for the franchise, but his
performance in his first run as Dumbledore was
stunted by the fact that he never read the books.
Rather than resuming Harris' spellbindingly
calm and wise demeanor, Gambon delivered a
much more stern and aggressive version of
the character for his first few outings.
"Harry! Did you put your
name in the Goblet of Fire?"
"No sir!"
"Did you ask one of the older
students to do it for you?"
"No sir!"
"You’re absolutely sure?"
"Yes."
Gambon would later summon up some sort of
chill pill that saved the role from being
ruined for children across the globe, but these
moments of mismatching between the beloved book
character and the screen interpretation
still cost the movies many house points
in the eyes of the true Potter fanatics.
Halle Berry taking over Michelle Pfeiffer's
role in Catwoman is perhaps the most infamous
example of recasting going terribly wrong.
DC's leather-clad heroine has appeared in
numerous Batman adaptations over the years, but
Pfeiffer's psychotically sexy performance in Tim
Burton's Batman Returns remains the cat's meow.
"I don't know about you Miss
Kitty but I feel so much yummier."
The actress initially intended
to reprise the role in the solo
spinoff. But after years of development woes,
her patience reached its limit and she
decided to concentrate on other commitments.
After a rigorous recruiting process,
Berry was ultimately chosen to climb
into the catsuit — and what a mess it all
was. The film was a complete disaster,
bombing hard at the box office while
cleaning up at the Razzies. Berry took
her Worst Actress win in good humor and even
turned up to accept her award in person.
Another error of judgment from the Batman
universe occurred when Michael Keaton handed
over the keys for Wayne Manor to Val Kilmer.
Keaton had portrayed the role in 1989's Batman
and its sequel Batman Returns, but he refused to
reprise the role in a third film after reading
the screenplay. When pressed for details, Keaton
later said that the script he was shown "sucked"
and that "it was just awful," pointing the
blame for his departure squarely at the writers.
Val Kilmer clearly didn't share Keaton's
opinion. The Tombstone star accepted the
role and went into the film knowing he'd have
to contend with a wide cast of wacky villains
as well as a new director. Joel Schumacher
ultimately shouldered a lot of the blame
for the badness of Batman Forever, though
his leading man didn't escape criticism.
"What am I?"
"Please, you're as blind as a bat."
He was quickly replaced with George Clooney
in Batman & Robin. The good news for Kilmer
is that Clooney's turn as the The Dark
Knight wasn't any more loved than his own,
and soon everyone forgot about
Kilmer's turn in the batmobile.
"Forget it, take it off. It’s Val Kilmer."
"Are you an actor?"
Roger Moore and Sean Connery each
made seven appearances as James Bond,
though many 007 fans will tell you that
Connery is the only Bond. A CBS News poll
concluded that 51 percent of Americans
chose Connery as their favorite Bond,
with Pierce Brosnan coming in a distant second.
George Lazenby, the man who replaced Connery in
the role for 1969's On Her Majesty's Secret
Service, received just 1 percent of the vote,
which tells you everything you need to know
about the gulf between these two actors.
While critical opinion toward the
film itself has softened over time,
Lazenby's performance is still a bone of
contention — inevitably compared to those
delivered by Connery in the franchise's five
previous entries. The Chicago Reader said that,
"George Lazenby has so much reserve as James Bond
that he makes Sean Connery seem
almost frenetic by comparison."
Reviews in the UK were just as
critical of the leading man's
turn as the British Secret Service
agent, with London-based outlet Time
Out calling him a "stunning nonentity"
fronting a film with "no redeeming features."
1981's The Clash of the Titans attempted to
give Greek mythology the Star Wars treatment,
taking the story of Perseus and turning it into
a sprawling epic. Director Desmond Davis went
with Harry Hamlin in the role of Perseus, a son
of Zeus who in legend beheads the Gorgon Medusa
in order to save his beloved Princess Andromeda
from a giant Kraken. Hamlin remains active in
the industry, though he's still arguably
best remembered for his turn as Perseus.
The same cannot be said for Sam Worthington,
best known as the star of James Cameron's
budding Avatar franchise. Director Louis
Leterrier entrusted the Australian with
the lead role in his 2010 remake, though his
choice was called into question when the negative
reviews started to pour in. Worthington's
earned his share of acclaim over the years,
but the Titans remake is one release he most
likely wouldn't mind leaving off his résumé;
Quickflix's Simon Miraudo questioned how
Worthington had ever managed to become a
Hollywood actor after watching his
performance as Perseus, in which
"[He] does nothing but glare. His battle speeches
are neither rousing nor
particularly intelligible."
Despite its name, 1984's Friday the
13th Part 4: The Final Chapter was
far from the last installment in this
long-running horror franchise. In fact,
eight more films have been made since the
so-called final chapter, though the one that
directly followed it marked a major dropoff
in quality. Part 4 has been described as,
"One of the last really excellent horror romps
that focus on character dynamic and family."
Felix Vasquez of Cinema Crazed
praised Corey Feldman for his
"standout performance as young Tommy Jarvis."
Feldman went on to make a name for himself in
The Goonies, Stand by Me, and The Lost Boys,
though before he did, he reprised his
Friday the 13th role in 1985's Part 5:
A New Beginning. Unfortunately, he only appeared
in the prologue, and a time jump meant he was
replaced by the painfully dull John Shepherd.
Teenage Tommy was static compared to his younger
self, though Shepherd shouldn't shoulder the
blame entirely. Some blamed what they called
the "hamfisted directing" of David Steinmann
while James Kendrick of Q Network argued that
"[The] gory antics are so restrained by the
insistence of the MPAA rating system that
the film feels like it was edited with
one of Jason's bloody-rusty weapons."
Veteran film critic Mark Kermode summed up 2015's
The Transporter Refueled with a single question:
"What exactly is the point of a
'Transporter' movie without Jason Statham?"
When it was revealed that Ed Skrein
was to replace Statham as Special
Forces op-turned-private driver Frank
Martin in the fourth Transporter film,
questions were raised about the former's
ability to carry the franchise forward.
Though the Transporter films didn't exactly change
the action movie landscape, they benefited from
Statham's presence, athletic prowess, and combat
skills. His replacement lacked that experience,
and it showed. Skrein began taking classes
in various martial arts disciplines as he
prepared for both The Transporter Refueled
and his role as Ajax in Deadpool, but even
he acknowledged that he was way behind many of
his peers in that department. He told the BBC,
"I'm very respectful and realize I'm not going to
be able to do things meant for
10 or 20 years of training."
The action in The Transporter Refueled
was ultimately limited by the new star's
fledgling abilities. Ed Skrein's one
and only outing as Frank Martin was a
commercial and critical flop that left the Luc
Besson-produced franchise dead in the water.
Rooney Mara took on the role of androgynous
computer hacker Lisbeth Salander starring
opposite Daniel Craig in 2011's The Girl with
the Dragon Tattoo. When the 2018 sequel The Girl
in the Spider's Web was announced, fans of David
Fincher's critically acclaimed first film were a
little disappointed that both Mara and Craig had
been recast, and so was Mara. She told Yahoo!,
"I was hopeful to come back, but
they decided to do a different
thing. It was always a character I wanted
to revisit, but that's not what happened."
Sverrir Gudnason replaced Daniel Craig,
while Claire Foy stepped into the pale,
pierced skin of Salander. Unfortunately, she
didn't look comfortable in it. At the time,
she was receiving acclaim for her turn as
the young Queen Elizabeth II in The Crown,
but Foy couldn't pull off Salander's
cold eccentricities with the same poise
as her predecessor. Critics were by and large
unimpressed with her version of the goth hacker,
with many questioning why she was chosen
for the part. The Observer's Wendy Ide said,
"Much as I admire her, Foy is miscast
here. She’s just too empathetic for a
role that requires an almost
reptilian lack of emotion."
IndieWire's senior film critic David Ehrlich
called her both "terrible [and] terribly miscast."
The first RoboCop stars Peter Weller as the
titular cyborg. He roams a dystopian crime-ridden
version of Detroit, mercilessly dealing with
lawbreakers. Weller reprised the role in RoboCop
2 but turned down the chance to play him again
in a third movie. Producers needed a replacement,
and their hearts were apparently set on a
little-known actor named Robert John Burke.
In a 2015 interview, Burke said,
"In God's great earth they thought I
was the only actor who could do it,
I don't know why. I think physically I poked
like Peter Weller, and I had also had extensive
karate training, pantomime training,
and body training, and I fit the suit."
Unsurprisingly, handing the lead role over to
the relatively inexperienced Burke just because
he kind of resembled Weller didn't work out very
well. He may have looked like him in the suit,
but as the New York Times said in
its review of the box office bomb,
"[Burke is] lacking his forerunner's
tongue-in-cheek glint of authoritarian machismo."
"You have the right to an attorney."
"What is thiiiiiis?"
From his delivery to the way he moved, Burke just
wasn't as convincing as RoboCop. As Empire noted,
he appeared to be "a lot less
comfortable with the hardware."
1988's Big is often cited as Tom Hanks' breakout
movie, but he actually announced himself as a
potential star some four years earlier in
Ron Howard's fantasy rom-com Splash. Hanks
plays Allen Bauer, a young man who returns to
the spot of what he believes was a near-death
hallucination to discover that the woman he
saw in the water the day he almost drowned
is indeed real. Allen falls for mermaid Madison
and ditches his life on land to live under the
sea with her in a goofy yet undeniably
feel-good ending. It's a beloved movie,
though the same cannot be said about the
obscure, made-for-TV sequel, Splash, Too.
Helmed by writer, director, and actor Greg
Antonacci, the highly forgettable and completely
unnecessary Splash, Too brought Allen and Madison
back to dry land, totally ignoring the fact that
the government wanted to lock her up in a lab
in the previous installment. Todd Waring took
over as Allen Bauer, but despite his best
efforts, he lacked the everyman charm and
comedic timing that was abundant in Hanks.
Film Fad said in its review of the sequel,
"The less said about the actors replacing
Tom Hanks and John Candy the better."
Dallas had its fair share of character
replacements during its run from 1978 to 1991,
as any show that airs for 14 seasons inevitably
does. But one that still stands out with fans
to this day is the role of Miss Ellie Ewing.
Barbara Bel Geddes originated the part and
played it right up until 1984, when she
left in order to have a quadruple bypass
heart surgery. At the time she was replaced
by Donna Reed, and fans were not into it.
In fact, fans were so not into it that six
months later, when Bel Geddes had recovered,
she was asked back onto the show.
Reed didn't go down without a fight,
though — she tried to sue and halt
production. In the end, the judge
didn't agree with her and the series carried
on. Bel Geddes continued playing Miss Ewing
for the remainder of the series, bringing
life to the character for 300 episodes.
When Suits hit airwaves in 2011, critics had
positive but somewhat mixed reviews on the
premise, which turned the tired legal drama format
on its head with the introduction of Mike Ross,
a wannabe lawyer without a degree, and
Harvey Specter, the hotshot attorney
who mentored him. Shot in Toronto, the series
wound up being a massive hit for the network,
and was considered the last of its blue-skies era.
"Hey, you ready for this?"
"Yeah, I am."
However, that all ended in 2017, when Patrick
J. Adams and Meghan Markle, who played Mike Ross
and his love interest Rachel Zane respectively,
announced they were leaving the show after seven
seasons. At that point another original series
star, Gina Torres, also exited, leaving the cast
down three members. As a result, the show brought
on Dulé Hill and Katherine Heigl, while upping
Amanda Schull from recurring to full-time status
in season 8. However, the new mix of characters
didn't resonate as well as the old school ones,
and the show wrapped for good in season 9.
It seems like networks have been trying
to recreate the soapy primetime success of
Desperate Housewives ever since that show went
off the air in 2012. ABC thought it came close
with the 2013 entry Mistresses, which failed
to earn critical praise but still snagged a
second-season renewal following its steamy
first-season summer run. Fans continued to
bake in the hotness of it all the following
summer, but when the show was renewed for a
third season, ABC revealed it was moving
production from Los Angeles to Vancouver.
That was bad news for star Alyssa Milano,
who couldn't be that far from her family.
Milano stepped away as a result, and
the show recruited Jennifer Esposito
to fill that void with her Calista Raines
character. That lasted one season and then
Esposito also left the series in order
to pursue other projects. Surprisingly,
the show was renewed for one more season,
but without Milano fans just didn't seem
that into it and the series was axed for
good after a very dramatic season 4 finale.
It's no secret that Julie Benz did not want
to exit Dexter. After she was killed off in
the show's fourth season, she admitted
to reporters that she, quote, "bawled"
and said it was the worst thing to ever happen
to her in her career. It seems as though fans
felt the same way. While the decision was purely a
creative one, the salt in the wound for passionate
viewers came in season 5 when Julia Stiles
was cast as Lumen Pierce, a new love interest
for Dexter. The character lasted the entire
season, and finally exited ahead of season 6.
For many it was a turning point, especially as
they watched the show go on to cast other guest
stars, like Colin Hanks and Yvonne
Strahovski, to fill the void. Then,
writers eventually went so far as to almost
pair Dexter up with his adoptive sister Deb.
Chemistry is particularly important when
casting a family sitcom, so fans were a little
concerned when Julia Butters left American
Housewife as the youngest Otto child ahead
of its fifth-season premiere. Butters brought a
notable charm to the character of Anna-Kat Otto,
so much so that when Quentin Tarantino saw her on
his screen he cast her as serious young actress
Trudi in Once Upon A Time in Hollywood. That gig
wound up being a game-changer for the young actor,
because all kinds of subsequent offers came
in and she left the ABC series to pursue them.
In turn, American Housewife snatched
up Giselle Eisenberg, fresh from her
four-season run on the CBS sitcom Life in
Pieces. While Eisenberg is undeniably talented,
it's been hard for fans to adapt to the
change following the show's return in 2020.
"Yeah...kids change."
It's no secret that the children on Tim Allen's
Last Man Standing changed pretty drastically over
the show's run. Amanda Fuller joined the
project in season two as Kristin Baxter,
replacing Alexandra Krosney, who
originated the role. Then there's
the fact that four different actors have
played the part of Kristin's son Boyd as
the character has aged over the years.
But it was Molly Ephraim's exit from the
series following season six that really
threw Last Man Standing fans for a loop.
As middle child Mandy, Ephraim had her share of
meaty storylines that made her a show fixture.
But when ABC canceled Last Man Standing in 2017
and Fox revived it for a seventh-season run,
Ephraim didn't go with it. She
had signed up for new projects,
and was unable to return. Molly McCook was cast
in her place, and although the series lasted
three seasons on Fox before its cancelation in
2021, the character was just never the same.
Now this is a story all about how the casting
on Fresh Prince got turned upside down. Fans
everywhere are familiar with the behind-the-scenes
strife that went down between Will Smith and
original Aunt Viv actress Janet Hubert, who played
the role for three notable seasons before refusing
to renew her contract under what she considered
to be a bad deal. As a result she exited the show,
and she was replaced by Daphne Maxwell Reid — an
actor who was originally considered for the role
but refused to audition because a TV show starring
a young rapper didn't sound like her thing.
"There are a lot of sick,
demented perverts out there."
"Greetings, all."
Although The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air went on
for three more seasons with the new Aunt Viv,
there was no replacing Hubert's comedic
timing. Later, when Smith got the gang
back together for the 2020 reunion, he
and Hubert sat down for the first time
to finally iron things out. The result was the
two Aunt Vivs meeting for the very first time,
as many fans wondered what the show could
have been had Hubert stayed on after all.
When the sixth season of this comedy kicked off
in 1969, viewers were left twitching harder than
Samantha and her magical nose when Emmy nominee
Dick York was suddenly gone as Darrin Stephens.
In his place was Dick Sargent, and fan speculation
as to what happened kicked into overdrive. As it
turned out, York had previously injured his
back pretty badly while shooting a movie,
and the pain led him down a dark path
of prescription pills. Eventually
he realized he had to leave the show,
and his career never really recovered.
As for Sargent? He stayed in the role until the
series finale in 1972. Many fans felt the series
wasn't the same, though, and it's worth noting
that although Sargent won a Most Irreplaceable
Replacement TV Land Award in 2006, he was never
nominated for an Emmy Award like his predecessor.
Have you heard the one about the two Beckys? When
Roseanne kicked off its first iteration back in
1988, it was actor Lecy Goranson who originated
the role of Becky, the eldest child to Dan and
Roseanne. Fast forward to season five, though, and
Goranson had enrolled in college, and as a result
she was only available to film part-time, usually
for a phone conversation. The following year
producers wanted Becky back in a more permanent
role, so they recast her with Sarah Chalke.
That was fine, but things got complicated
when Goranson briefly returned in Season 8
after finishing school. The following
year Chalke was back in the role,
and "the two Beckys" became a running thing
that frustrated some viewers. To their relief,
both actors were asked back for the Roseanne
revival in 2018, but only Goranson returned
to play Becky. Producers hired Chalke to
instead play a character named Andrea,
who asked Becky to be her surrogate in
a clever wink to the whole situation.
For five and a half seasons, Nashville fans
followed Connie Britton's superstar character,
Rayna Jaymes, as she balanced motherhood,
singing, and reconnecting with her one true
love, Deacon Claybourne. But that all came
crashing down when Britton shocked fans and
exited the series in 2017 with a devastating
storyline that left her family all alone.
It turned out Britton was ready for a change,
but she was having a hard time letting go
of the people she worked with. So when CMT
revived Nashville for a fifth season after
ABC axed it at the end of its run in 2016,
Britton decided it was finally time to move
on. After the fictional singer's death there
were plenty of other characters to root for,
and the show may have ultimately survived. But
then the writers introduced Kaitlin Doubleday
as Jessie Caine, a new love interest for
Deacon, and loyal fans were definitely not
happy. The series took a bit of a dive, and
season 6 ultimately wound up being the last.
Throughout its eight-season run, House
had a history of replacing characters to
switch up the storyline and keep things
fresh, but Season 7 is when the casting
situation really got out of control. That
year, Olivia Wilde took a leave of absence
from her fan-favorite gig as Thirteen to
film Cowboys & Aliens, while original actor
Lisa Edelstein announced her departure as
Dr. Lisa Cuddy. Considering the shakeups,
it seemed pretty clear to longtime fans that
the series was nearing its expiration date.
To try and inject new life into the
show, producers hired Odette Annable
and Charlyne Yi to play the latest
fellows alongside Amber Tamblyn,
but the new crew never quite lived up
to the original cast, and as season 8
was in progress, Fox announced that
it would also be the show's last.
Today Beverly Hills 90210 is also known as
TV's most famous zip code. But before the
show earned that status, its original cast had to
win over primetime fans with its older actors and
soapy storylines. Enter Jason Priestley and
Shannen Doherty as the famous Walsh twins,
Brandon and Brenda. From the start, fans
were into their chemistry with the show's
other original cast members, but behind the
scenes it was a different story. Reports of
on-set tension between Doherty and the rest of
the cast — specifically Jenie Garth — surfaced,
and in 1994, Doherty was
axed from the show for good.
That year she was replaced by Tiffani Thiessen,
who had her own fanbase from her days as Kelly on
Saved by the Bell. But not all fans were
into the new character, Valerie Malone,
a family friend of the Walshes. It was clear
Val was meant to replace Brenda, but Saved by
the Bell fans weren't sure how to receive this
new, adult version of the actor. Meanwhile,
the character had her moments, but she was no
Brenda, and the tone of the series changed with
her casting. She stayed on for most of the rest of
the series, but to this day you can ask any 90210
fan which character they relate to most, and you
probably won't find many Valerie stans out there.
Steve Carell was a well-known comic
force from The Daily Show and Anchorman
before he got his biggest break with the
small screen comedy series The Office.
The show was an American adaptation of
Ricky Gervais' BBC sitcom of the same
name and became wildly popular with audiences.
Carell's film career started to take off
shortly thereafter, with starring roles in
movies like The 40 Year-Old Virgin, Little Miss
Sunshine, and Crazy Stupid Love, elevating him
to household name status. So, in 2013, when
Carell's contract with The Office was up,
he opted to walk away from the series even though
it was still a critical and ratings hit for NBC.
The awkward, lovelorn Michael Scott finally
found love with HR director Holly, and they
moved away to Colorado. But Dunder Mifflin still
needed a boss, and that came in the form of oily,
unsettling Robert California,
CEO of its parent company Sabre.
"Well,
I will not be blackmailed by some ineffectual,
privileged, effete, soft penis debutante"
And it was all downhill from there. The show's
critical favor and viewership numbers took a
nosedive, and the series finally came to
a close after two Carell-free seasons.
For its first six seasons, The X-Files was a
huge hit for Fox and made its on-screen pair of
paranormal investigators international stars. But
prior to the start of the series' seventh season,
David Duchovny sued the network, claiming
that it had sold rights to reruns of the
show at a discount to its own affiliates
and cheated the stars out of profits.
While the lawsuit was eventually settled, it was
filed right when Duchovny was negotiating working
on future seasons of the show, and neither he
nor Fox were keen to continue working together.
So, a deal was reached: Duchovny's character,
Fox Mulder would mysteriously disappear at the
end of Season 7, and would only appear in a
handful of episodes in Season 8. But Gillian
Anderson's Agent Scully still needed someone to
work with in his absence, so producers auditioned
dozens of actors and eventually settled on Robert
Patrick to come in as FBI agent John Doggett.
Another actress was also hired on
in case Anderson decided to leave
the show after her contract ended,
too. It didn't much matter, though,
because without Duchovny in his
regular role, viewers tuned out.
"You saved me. As difficult
and as frustrating as it’s been
sometimes, your g–damn strict rationalism and
science has saved me a thousand times over."
This ABC sitcom was forced to
reformat after the unexpected
death of its star. 8 Simple Rules was
built around TV legend John Ritter,
who starred as cranky suburban dad desperately
trying to rein in his wild teenage children.
Filming had just begun on the second season of
the series when Ritter fell ill on the set and
sought medical treatment. He died later that day
of a heart defect that had never been diagnosed.
ABC announced that the show
would go on — and it did,
with some necessary changes. No
longer a show about a cranky dad,
it became one about a family trying to pick up
the pieces after the death of its patriarch.
Two new stars joined the cast to fill the
void left by Ritter: cousin C.J. and Grandpa
Jim. But without Ritter, the show only lasted
another season before being shelved for good.
Actor/musician Steve Burns beat out roughly
1,000 other actors in 1996 for the only human
role on Blue's Clues, Nickelodeon's
interactive, animation/live action
hybrid show for preschoolers. Burns played
the striped-shirted host and owner of the
cartoon dog named Blue — he'd talk directly
to the young viewers at home, urging them
to help him solve each episode's riddle or
mystery by yelling things at their screens.
In 2002, after about 100 episodes,
Burns decided it was time to leave
the series. He wanted to take on
other roles as well as perform music.
Nickelodeon hired actor Donovan Patton to be the
new host of Blue's Clues, playing Steve's younger
brother Joe. So as not to traumatize or confuse
the show's very young viewers, Steve carefully
explained that he was leaving for college, and
Joe would be looking after Blue. Patton as Joe
proved to be the gentle and able host Blue's
Clues needed, but he just couldn't replace
someone so closely associated with the role to
an army of toddlers. After around 50 episodes
with Patton as Joe, Blue's Clues was canceled.
This comedy about medical interns desperately
trying to figure out what they were
doing as they worked in a hospital was
a critically-acclaimed, Emmy-nominated
hit over its first few seasons on NBC.
The network dropped the show after seven
seasons, only to see ABC pick it up. The
show's writers and cast prepared a true
series finale at the end of the year,
only for ABC to unexpectedly renew
the series again for season 9.
But star Zach Braff, the focus of
the show as young doctor John Dorian,
was ready to move on to other things.
"Onward! Yee-haw!"
"Oh good god."
So the show was retooled and rebooted, no
longer taking place at a teaching hospital
but at a medical school. Doctor Cox and Doctor
Turk were now teachers instead of active surgeons.
"I'm just back to teach some classes."
Replacing Braff as the center of the
show and narrator was Dr. Lucy Bennett,
but the big changes were too much to take, and
the ninth season of Scrubs was also its last.
Michael J. Fox returned to regular series
television for the first time since the end
of Family Ties with Spin City. On the ABC sitcom,
he played Mike Flaherty, a wheeler-dealer for a
New York City deputy mayor. Two years later, Fox
announced that he had been battling Parkinson's
disease and left the show to spend more time
raising funds for research on the disease.
Replacing him as deputy mayor was a guy named
Charlie Crawford, portrayed by Charlie Sheen.
With Fox out, the show became more of a romantic
comedy surrounding Sheen and Heather Locklear's
characters, but viewership tanked shortly after
the replacement, so ABC cut the cord on Spin City.
"I guess you guys aren’t ready for that yet.
But your kids are gonna love it."
Delta Burke had not been happy on
the set of Designing Women for years. She even
claimed that a producer routinely screamed at
cast members and told them they were expendable
and criticized Burke when she gained weight.
"Are you serious?!"
CBS grew so tired of Burke publicly
trashing the show's producers and
the network in the press that
they fired her from the show,
and co-star Jean Smart followed her
out the door shortly thereafter.
"Every time I look over at the
sofa I kinda miss seeing her."
That meant that Designing Women
had lost half of its main cast,
but the show was still a ratings draw, so
the network brought in some replacements.
"Now I know that all of our nerves are a
little bit jangly because of this silly
old money situation but you know what we
gotta do? We've got to look for the light."
Julia Duffy arrived as Suzanne's cousin,
and Jan Hooks came in as Carlene,
Charlene's sister. Despite ratings on par
with previous years, CBS fired Duffy after
her sole season on the series, and replaced
her with Judith Ivey as a rich Texan widow
named B.J. Poteet. It didn't do much good,
because CBS moved the show to Friday nights,
where it slipped into ratings
oblivion — and then cancellation.
"And that… Is the night the
lights went out in Georgia"
After seven seasons of riding on a high — ratings
wise, at least — two of That 70s Show's main stars
decided to step away from the series. Topher
Grace decided to leave the show in order to more
fiercely pursue his blossoming film career and
was written out of the eighth season altogether.
Meanwhile, Ashton Kutcher decided his
time in the bell bottoms was done too,
but did appear for a few of
Season 8's early episodes.
To replace two very big holes in its cast,
producers hired Mad TV veteran Josh Meyers.
His character, Randy, joins Hyde's record store
Grooves and has a brief relationship with Donna.
But Randy didn't have much time to mesh with
the ensemble because the decimated cast led
to diminished popularity for the show, and it
was ultimately canned at the end of the season.
"You have the right to remain BURNED."
Even though Community never had a huge
audience during its five-year run on NBC,
it was still a critically-acclaimed
comedy with a passionate cult following.
Five seasons was ultimately NBC's limit, but
internet giant Yahoo! stepped in and renewed
Community for a sixth season, intending to
position the comedy as a premiere offering
on its streaming service Yahoo! Screen. Original
regulars Joel McHale, Gillian Jacobs, Danny Pudi,
Ken Jeong, and Alison Brie followed the series
to Yahoo!, but the show had already been losing
cast members and left and right, and kept
losing them as it transitioned to streaming.
Chevy Chase, Donald Glover, and
Yvette Nicole Brown were not part
of the regular cast of Community's
sixth season. New actors were added,
including Keith David and Paget
Brewster. But it just didn't work out,
and there was no seventh season of Community on
Yahoo! Screen — or anywhere. Not enough people
tuned in and the show didn't generate as much
advertising revenue as Yahoo! had hoped. The
revenue was so small that it effectively led
to the complete shutdown of Yahoo! Screen.
"Show may be canceled and moved to the
internet where it turns out tens of
millions were watching the whole time. May
not matter. Fake commercial may end with
disclaimer gag which may descend into vain
Chuck Lorre-esque rant by narcissistic creator"
Sleepy Hollow, Fox's supernatural police drama,
was always a little bit different than other cop
shows. For starters, one of its main characters
was Ichabod Crane from Washington Irving's
short story "The Legend of Sleepy Hollow,"
who comes back to life in the present day
after having died 200 or so years prior.
Crane then helps fight supernatural menaces
alongside police lieutenant Abbie Mills. Over
three seasons, Sleepy Hollow settled into
its role as a quirky police procedural,
and then it did the unthinkable — Abbie died
and actress Nicole Beharie left the series.
Despite a steep loss of viewers from
season 1 to season 3, Sleepy Hollow
returned for a fourth season without Abbie.
Ichabod was now partnered with a Homeland
Security agent named Diana Thomas. The cast
reboot didn't do Sleepy Hollow any favors,
though. The show fell even further
in the ratings and was soon canceled.
Step by Step was an ABC sitcom
about Carol and Frank Lambert,
two single parents who bring their families
together. In addition to all their kids,
Frank's nephew Cody lived in a van outside
the house. Cody was a good-natured, air-headed
California dude, basically a sitcom version
of Ted, from Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure.
"And I'm Ted Theodore Logan."
"Yeah!"
Affable and enthusiastic acting by Sasha Mitchell
made the character a fan favorite. But in 1995,
when Mitchell was arrested for spousal
assault. He was convicted later that year,
and sentenced to three years of probation
and spousal abuse counseling. Mitchell wound
up behind bars for violating his parole,
and reportedly attacked his wife again.
At the beginning of the sixth season
of Step by Step, Cody was gone,
replaced by Jean-Luc, a heavily accented
hairdresser colleague of Carol's. Playing
Jean-Luc was Bronson Pinchot, best
known for playing the excitable,
heavily-accented Balki on Perfect Strangers
and the excitable, heavily-accented Serge
in Beverly Hills Cop. The new cast addition
didn't work, and ABC canceled Step by Step
at the end of the season. The show then moved
to CBS for a final year... without Pinchot.
After the first season of The Facts of Life,
the number of main characters was cut from 10 to
just five: Eastland boarding school housemother
Mrs. Garrett and four female students. After
those four graduated in the fourth season,
Mrs. Garrett opened a gourmet shop and hired
her former students. And after season seven,
Mrs. Garrett herself, Charlotte Rae, left
the show. She thought it was time to move on,
later telling Entertainment Weekly that
the show could continue on without her.
But producers loved the show's dynamic of a wise
older woman doling out advice to young women,
so they created the role of Mrs. Garrett's
sister Beverly Ann. However, the replacement
didn't quite work, and by the ninth season, The
Facts of Life was unceremoniously cancelled.
American Idol has created a number
of stars, such as Kelly Clarkson,
Jennifer Hudson, Adam Lambert, and, of course,
Simon Cowell. Audiences couldn't get enough of
the judge, who was often brutally and
hilariously honest with contestants.
"Okay. Best singer in America."
"Yeah."
"Right, I can honestly say you
are the worst singer in America."
Cowell was the biggest star of the series,
which was the most-watched show on TV for an
unprecedented eight straight seasons. But
in 2010, after nine seasons, he moved on,
in part to develop the American version
of his British talent series The X Factor.
Idol producers had a hard time replacing
Cowell, as well as fellow original judge
Paula Abdul. The Idol judges' table saw a
lot of stars take a stab at it, but actual
singers just couldn't fill the void left by
the music industry guy who criticizes singers.
"Maybe we've made a mistake."
"I think we may have made a mistake."
"We made a big mistake."
NBC's critically-acclaimed but low-watched comedy
had no plans to replace one of its characters
and best-known star — but tragedy forced the
producers' hand. Between the show's fourth and
fifth season, star Phil Hartman was shot to death
by his troubled wife. It was a horrific crime,
and a devastating loss for the show. But
in order to complete enough episodes to
sell the show into syndication, NewsRadio
was picked up for another season anyway.
In the season premiere, it was
explained that Hartman's character,
pompous radio newsreader Bill McNeal,
died of a sudden heart attack. Replacing
him at the newsreader's desk was a new
character, Max Louis. Weird, insecure,
and wholly unqualified for the position, Max
was portrayed by Hartman's friend and Saturday
Night Live costar Jon Lovitz. While Lovitz
is a great comic actor, he just couldn't
overcome the sadness looming over NewsRadio.
Lovitz's first season would be the show's last.
For the Fox television adaptation of Lethal
Weapon, Clayne Crawford took over for Mel Gibson
as "loose cannon" Martin Riggs. And if on-set
reports published by Variety are any indication,
Crawford was even harder to control than his
character. In an episode he directed, a special
effects explosion went awry, sending a piece
of debris at co-star Damon Wayans. When Wayans
complained, Crawford referred to his co-star as
a "crybaby." Another time he reportedly screamed
and swore at a group of children who wandered
near; on yet another occasion, he reportedly
proved so hard to work with that a director
walked off the set in the middle of a shoot.
In May 2018, after two seasons, producers
eliminated what they thought was the root
cause of the show's problems and fired Crawford.
They rushed to find somebody to replace him,
and quickly hired Seann William Scott to play
Wesley Cole, a new partner for Detective Roger
Murtaugh. Scott couldn't save the show, however.
All that tension didn't totally dissipate,
with Wayans announcing that he planned to
leave the series in the middle of the season.
Fox decided to wash their hands of the whole
thing in May 2019 and canceled Lethal Weapon.
From 1998 to 2007, Kevin James and Leah
Remini starred on the popular CBS sitcom
King of Queens. James would go on to star in a
string of movies like Grown Ups and Paul Blart:
Mall Cop, but in 2016, he returned to the weekly
CBS sitcom grind with Kevin Can Wait. James
portrayed Kevin Gable, a family man who has
to delay retiring from his police job due to
family and money issues. Playing opposite James
was Erinn Hayes as Kevin's wife, Donna Gable.
At least, that's how it was for the first
season. Kevin Can Wait producers revamped
the show for season two: They killed
off Donna Gable and fired Hayes. James
explained the decision to the
New York Daily News by saying:
"We were literally just running out of ideas."
They also brought in a new face, who was really
a familiar face. Surprisingly, Leah Remini joined
Kevin Can Wait as Kevin's business partner,
Vanessa. However, the nostalgic retooling
couldn't overcome the weird behind-the-scenes
shakeup, and ratings actually dropped in season
two. After the conclusion of the sitcom's second,
ill-fated season, CBS didn't wait to cancel Kevin.
An ensemble dramedy with a culturally diverse
cast set in an often surreal rural Alaska,
Northern Exposure was radically different from
most other shows on television. Rob Morrow
starred as Dr. Joel Fleischman, a snobby New York
City doctor who heads north to service the tiny
town of Cicely. Northern Exposure was a big hit,
reaching the top 20 in the ratings and earning
four straight Emmy nominations for Outstanding
Drama Series, and winning the prize in 1992.
But Dr. Fleischman's desire to leave Alaska
never faded, and Morrow wanted to bounce,
too. Halfway through the show's sixth
season, Morrow fled Northern Exposure,
reportedly to pursue new acting challenges and a
movie career. Replacing him was a new physician:
Dr. Phillip Capra, portrayed by Paul Provenza, a
respected stand-up comedian who had little acting
experience apart from his work on sitcoms.
That inexperience seems to have showed;
after just half a season with Provenza at the
helm, the network canceled Northern Exposure.
The high school sitcom Head of the Class debuted
on ABC in 1986. It explored the relationships
between a diverse group of highly advanced
Manhattan students and their history teacher
Charlie Moore, played by Howard Hesseman. A
big part of why Head of the Class worked is
that it was ensemble-focused; the various
kids had personal and academic problems,
and Mr. Moore helped them sort things
out. Hesseman portrayed Moore with
understatement and subtlety, letting
his younger co-stars take center stage.
However, the actor hated
Head of the Class. In 1989,
he told a reporter that he thought the
show didn't have much worth. He said:
"We're not doing the show that
I was led to believe I'd do,
and it's difficult for me to get off that."
Unsurprisingly, Hesseman left the show in
1990. In his place was Scottish comedian
Billy Connolly as a teacher named Billy McGregor.
All of a sudden, a show about high school kids'
problems was a show about wacky Mr. McGregor.
ABC seemed to realize that, too. In 1991,
the network canceled Head of the Class and quickly
ordered up a new show called Billy. Connolly
continued to play McGregor, who was now living as
a boarder in a California single mother's house.